You’re probably too young to remember, but
at one point, almost all the Earth’s landmass
was clumped into one gigantic supercontinent
called Pangea.
Land was like you and your friends from high
school: one tightly knit bunch.
But then you graduate, people move away, you
lose touch, and suddenly it’s 250 million
years later and the world’s all spread out
and everyone but you is getting married.
Sorry, got lost in the metaphors.
But the thing is, those forces that pulled
the Earth’s land in all directions are still
here today, so what will the earth look like
in another 250 million years?
That is a very long way off so no one can
say for sure, but we can make educated guesses
based on what’s happening right now.
See the Earth’s surface isn’t set in stone.
The crust and upper part of the molten mantle,
together called the lithosphere, are broken
up into several tectonic plates that fit together
like puzzle pieces.
These plates glide around on the Earth’s
molten interior, creating mountains and volcanoes
where they collide, new crust where they separate,
and earthquakes where they slide past each
other.
The plates only move centimeters each year,
but sometimes dramatic events happen suddenly.
Like the giant crack that just opened up in
Africa.
In March of 2018 a huge crack appeared in
Kenya.
There are a few possible explanations, like
heavy rain or underground water washing away
sediment.
But it’s also possible that Africa is splitting
in two.
The same forces that cause the plates to move
can also break them apart, and right now it
looks like the African plate is breaking up
into unequal parts: the Somali and Nubian
plates.
Africa isn’t the only continent making a
break for it, Australia is on the move too.
In fact the entire country is moving north
so quickly that it could throw GPS systems
off in just a few years.
If you take what we see happening now, you
can run the clock forward a bit and extrapolate
what is likely to happen.
There’s no guarantees though, since things
move slow and steady right up until they don’t,
and some unforeseen catastrophe changes everything.
Anything past 50 million years in the future
is really speculative, but it’s fun, so
let’s speculate!
Projections from Chris Scotese, a professor
from Northwestern University, have North and
South America splitting up within the next
30 million years when Panama breaks away from
Colombia.
This is of course due to man’s hubris when
we dug the Panama canal.
Kidding, the same forces that slid Panama
into the place it is today will snap it off
of South America again sometime in the future.
I guess Teddy Roosevelt could have just waited
a while
Down under will get a little less down and
under as Australia makes a bee line for Asia.
According to Scotese’s estimates it will
smack into China, getting all up in it’s
business and fusing together within 65 million
years.
Meanwhile the northern edge of Africa will
have joined up with the southern edge of Europe,
completely eliminating the mediterranean sea.
So don’t buy beachfront property in Italy,
it’ll be worthless.
Around 100 million years from now the Pacific
ocean will start getting bigger as the americas
drift towards europe, but not before Alaska
nicks a piece of Russia.
And while all this is happening Antarctica
will start drifting into the Indian ocean
to see what the party’s all about.
It will join Brazil and Madagascar at the
southern tip of Africa while Newfoundland
smooshes into the Ivory Coast.
In 250 million years, we could be looking
at a new supercontinent, Pangea Proxima.
Of course this is one possibility, another
one is North America crosses the arctic ocean
to snuggle up to Russia, forming another supercontinent
dubbed Amasia.
It’ll amaze-ya.
It’s kind of poetic that the whole gang
could get back together again.
Of course, in all likelihood it’ll just
break up again and the cycle will continue
until the earth’s molten interior cools
or something else causes tectonic activity
to stop.
But that’s way in the future, for now just
enjoy the ride.
Especially you, Australia, hang on tight.
Tectonic plates move between 2 and 7 centimeters
each year, which is about the same speed your
fingernails and hair grows, respectively.
Thanks for tuning in, and come back for more videos from Seeker.